hello everybody and welcome back her not
back welcome to a brand-new let's play
of the cry for your custom campaign out
of it out of it
okay it's been a while since I've been
in cry for Wow that loud
I'm not to crank that down and post but
it's been a while since I've been back
in cry fear and if any of you have
watched my cry here let's play you know
that it's a great game it's got the
ability to have your own custom
campaigns by like amnesia a little
harder to do because it's has to be done
through obviously the hammer standard
developer kit which is a lot harder to
work with than the amnesia one I'm
guessing I don't know I've never made an
amnesia custom campaign but I know I've
made a half-life one and it is tough ty
way let's get to it
natsu medium okie dokie
out of it
nice dark
can't even see what's going on at WN u k
two three eight zero that's the maker
everything was different back then I did
whatever I wanted to do all the time but
ever since this one time I've gone clean
that acid he gave me had to have been
bad then again I never trusted that guy
two months earlier chapter one a bad
trip
where are you come home as soon as
possible it's getting dark okay I must
be a leftover from before that looks a
lot bigger than I remember it if you
know what I mean nothing seriously the
hand looks a lot bigger whatever so we
got basic inventory six slots quick
select slots ah the doors work oh I know
oh boy I'm starting to remember why I
fear was scary something is blocking the
door on the other side locked okay
all right
locked
in case you didn't know cry fear is
based on the half-life 180 so it's kind
of old but it's still they did a lot of
changes to it so it looks pretty good
comparatively Alice's nothing
hello
hello okay someone [ __ ] this door up
okay there we go
that doors perfectly fine yeah well
creepy posters what dal okay I'm
guessing the premises I'm trying to go
the maintenance story is locked door
won't move and I can hear something
moving on the other side that's not good
okay go box if I punch it punch it punch
the two box yep
after you remember everything here is
friends swedenland so i'm bringing back
the swedish accent hey okay so oh wait
what armor oh boy oh boy I have a quick
oh yeah there's no quicksaving this one
so you've just got to go
why can you sprint in place yeah
you ugly movie man I guess I'm coming
out the side of your face oh wait out
your brain oh boy oh boy you think I'd
be more worried about a dead guy being
on the floor Brett hey I should use this
phone thing call 9-1-1
okay that's fine what's this key like
that knife switchblade knife now watch
this
leet moves that I remembered oh yeah
looks another something that step yeah
the door handle it bro let me guess the
guy is standing up now yep
the body's gone hmm
god dammit I should have expected that
oh no a Dodge alt oh man I shouldn't
expected that I was like obvious oh man
ah I should have I should have known
that was coming I'm an idiot
look your eyeballs I remember I remember
now okay I got the key to something main
tenth one wasn't there like a
maintenance thing down here yeah this
door right gonna drag it over to use
there we go okay
okay all right hello oh I didn't even
look like a door ha oh god [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you whipped up [ __ ] hell
yeah unleash that on me oh ho ring
around the Teddy
don't just unleash a lady in white on me
right now right off the bat right off
the bat oh man
okay mm who's there
lot stop knocking hmm this place looks
just like my apartment do I have a gun
in my apartment oh I can record my
thoughts and increases hey it's got my
old saves look that's back that was the
last time I played cry for your back in
May 30th that was a long time ago I mean
wow no joke locked locked was why is my
apartment locked ha oh okay
locked lock open
okay but oh no oh no oh no oh yeah oh no
oh god damn it god damn it shut up [ __ ]
up shut up oh you hurt I don't have
morphine or heroin right now oh oh
alright this game I think I remember
yeah I don't liked him Oh locked locked
locked not locked
oh this looks lovely
hmm
locked ah sillies hole again holy crap
oh no this is it what what da hell Oh
ah
not from afraid of monsters but I don't
like where this is going
hey this does nothing
hmm where'd that come from
are you what
oh shut up
OSHA oh shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up shut up daddy Oh what
are you I've never seen anything like
you before my life died oh oh yeah oh oh
I was expecting the head I knew that was
gonna pop up hmm hmm that's like based
off the lady with the metal arms we
serve some custom miles and forgive me
no no gun yes please stop [ __ ] what
God what everything hair that's freaky I
like it that they changed some models
don't like that though
nope uh-uh boy right in the face and you
too
can you even hurt me not taking any
chances
there we go I probably gotten through
there oh oh it's okay
you know getting a bad trip I probably
summer derd like ten people
Oh oh that's so that's a gorilla's
poster isn't it looks like it
Oh oh boy
actually you know for an ounce the gun
out
Oh
oh there's no window there okay
ah now I'm gonna lose it in this game I
like if you guys remember I lost it
quite a lot that can the original cry
here mm-hmm not all anchor won't gonna
happen refrigerators are locked that's
not of course it's not walk right into
the fall That's not me gonna break these
wait can I punch them
oh those aren't meat
those are people's
Oh
oh how is it not 15 minutes yet Oh God
Oh okay I'm okay I'm okay here's the
from this year
Lou doorknob or dub you're the dog heads
I [ __ ] I almost summoned a demon from
another dimension
yeah good lord yeah yeah yeah oh man
come on oh by like two and a half months
man has it really been that long
up up up up up up ah aids the bed guys
I'm not really worried about the bed
guys I can you can basically just run
around the bed guys they're not that
scary
whoa what up and way they couldn't move
that fast before
there's something's up what dial maybe
they changed all that
look blocked they still haven't hit me
so what did that guy's flying man okay
whatever but what's that oh yeah ammo
and actually and that's all the time I
got for this episode I'll pick this
right back up so don't worry about that
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye